wading through the trenches of Mario
Paul Southeastern Ukraine Sean Penner a
former British soldier part of the
Ukrainian Army since 2018 filming here
with Sky News just weeks before the
outbreak of war and his capture by
Russian forces
now safely back in the UK with his
family but memories of recent months and
the anniversary of the Russian invasion
Loom large where were you what happened
how quickly did it build up well we got
stood two about four o'clock in the
morning and we knew something was
happening my boss had just spoke speaks
really good English says you've got to
get to positions Russia come across the
border
it's on what happens in that moment your
adrenaline's going you're nervous you're
scared you know part of people aren't
scared I was petrified it's Russia
within days Russian forces Advanced
bombarding
surrounding Mario Paul a city quickly
Under Siege just so intense me and my
team we called it Phil Collins you know
it sounds just like that beat as it
comes in very slow builds up and then
it's but you've been in combat a lot
yeah had you ever seen anything like
this no it was just nothing like the the
carelessness of it the bombing of
schools I saw a score with just the kids
uh coats hanging up and bags on there uh
where they've been evacuated and put in
a Cellar and they just hit the school
didn't care about it under sustained
attack Shawn tried to escape but was
quickly captured by Russian forces made
prisoner detained imprisoned tortured
electrocuted you feel like your muscles
are popping out of your
um your body and the next day my legs
inflated
fed just bread and water for 50 days and
then accused of being a mercenary
sentenced to death in a Russian proxy
Court later released in a prisoner
Exchange
distressing Reflections a story hard to
hear about a war that wages on Beth
Rigby Sky News